Roger Federer ist der wohl
berühmteste Schweizer weltweit.
Nach ganz oben geschafft
hat es auch Topmodel Ronja Furrer.
Eine der bekanntesten
Schweizer Marken
trägt Karl Kieliger
in die Welt hinaus.
Ihre Geschichten sind "Schweizer
Erfolgsgeschichten - grenzenlos gut".
Am Anfang waren ein gelber Filzball
und ein Tennisracket,
das Roger Federer kaum mehr
aus der Hand legen wollte.
Seitdem ist das Ausnahmetalent
auf Erfolgstour
und bereits jetzt
eine lebende Legende.
Er ist ganz oben
im Tennisolymp angekommen:
unser King Roger.
(Speaker) The best we've ever seen.
Please, welcome back
from Switzerland: Roger Federer!
* Frenetischer Jubel *
(Speaker) Roger Federer!
Virtuosität und Weltgewandtheit
gepaart mit Coolness
machen ihn zum Vorzeigeschweizer:
This means the world to me.
Thank you so, so much!
Er lässt uns
von einer perfekten Welt träumen.
Wenn Roger im Rampenlicht steht,
schaut die Welt
immer auch ein wenig auf die Schweiz.
Es macht mich sehr stolz,
das auf der ganzen Welt
zeigen zu dürfen, zu repräsentieren.
Diese Möglichkeit
bekommen nicht alle. Ganz ehrlich.
Deshalb sehe ich das als Privileg
und als Glücksfall.
Ich mache es auch gerne.
Ich bin sehr, sehr stolz darauf,
Schweizer und
irgendwie auch Botschafter zu sein.
310 Wochen die Weltrangnummer 1,
100-mal Sieger in Wimbledon,
20-mal Grand-Slam-Gewinner.
Er ist  d e r  Superstar und trotzdem
typisch schweizerisch: bescheiden.
Das ist nur für uns beide.
- Bitte ein Autogramm.
Here we go!
Wirf ihn runter!
* Schrei *
Vielen Dank!
- Danke!
Gern geschehen,
macht's gut, ciao, ciao.
Auch mitten im Hype bleibt Roger
Roger - und ganz der Schweizer.
Ich glaube,
er hat mich auf dem Boden behalten.
wir können auch euphorisch sein,
aber nicht sofort.
Man muss sich zuerst beweisen.
Es kam nicht gleich durch meinen
ersten Junioren-Wimbledonsieg.
In einem anderen Land wäre ich
auf jeder Titelseite gelandet.
Es hätte geheissen,
ich sei der nächste Superstar.
Das passierte
zwar auch kurz in der Schweiz,
aber es flachte sofort wieder ab.
Man sagte: "Wollen mal schauen,
was du nächste Woche kannst."
Das hat sich wie ein Faden durch
meine ganze Karriere durchgezogen.
Meine Eltern,
meine Familie, Freunde,
jeder hielt mich auf dem Boden,
liess mich nicht abheben.
Dieser Aspekt der Schweiz
hat mich am stärksten geprägt.
Ich hatte nie das Gefühl, ich sei
besser, als ich tatsächlich war -
eher das Gegenteil, und ich müsse
mich immer wieder neu beweisen.
Mit 17
machte ihn der Sieg in Wimbledon
mit einem Schlag zum Weltspieler.
Mit 17 war er aber auch
noch immer der Baselbieter Junge:
Ich? Ich bin Schweizer Junior.
Ich trainiere bei Swiss Tennis.
Sonst bin ich
halt ein normaler Junge.
Der Tennisvirus
wurde schon früh gesetzt,
gradlinig ging Federer seinen Weg.
Von der Konsequenz her
irgendwie schweizerisch,
von der Risikobereitschaft her
dann doch wieder nicht.
* Dynamische Klavierklänge *
Wenn die Leute mich fragten,
was ich so mache,
und ich sagte, ich spiele Tennis,
fragten sie: "Was noch?"
Ich: "Ich spiele nur Tennis."
Da war es fast so: "Oh, nur?"
Darauf ich:
"Ja, offenbar 'nur' Tennis."
"Sorry,
dass ich nichts anderes mache."
"Ich probiere es. Wenn es nicht
klappt, gehe ich wieder zur Schule."
Da könnten wir uns etwas abschauen
von anderen Ländern,
die gross träumen, denken, alles sei
möglich, man könne Bäume ausreissen.
Damit haben wir z.T. in der Schweiz
immer noch ein bisschen Mühe.
Anders seine südafrikanische Mutter
Lynette und Vater Robert.
Sie unterstützen den Traum
ihres Sohnes von Anfang an.
Auch Mirka, die Frau an seiner Seite,
lässt ihn Grenzen sprengen.
Als ehemalige Profispielerin ist sie
für ihn Partnerin auf Augenhöhe.
Der Federer-Clan
macht für Roger die Welt zur Heimat
und ist wichtiger Teil
des Erfolgsrezepts.
(Speaker) From Switzerland:
Roger Federer!
* Frenetischer Jubel *
Wann immer möglich
sind die Kinder dabei,
wenn ihr Vater
die Tenniswelt in Atem hält.
Applaus von Lenny
ist dem Papa gewiss.
Ich musste schmunzeln. Ich dachte:
"Wow, er sitzt in der ersten Reihe."
Ich wusste nicht, dass er überhaupt
an den Match kommt.
Ich dachte, evtl. kommen die Kinder,
war aber nicht sicher.
Häufig spiele ich in der Nacht.
Manchmal schlafen sie sogar schon.
Aber heute um 13 Uhr ist es ideal:
Da können sie vorbeikommen,
zu Mittag essen
ihre Freunde hier im Klub treffen.
Darum hat es mich gefreut,
dass alle Kinder gekommen sind
und jetzt schon länger durchhalten.
Das hat mich sehr gefreut.
* Elektronische Klänge *
Von Solothurn nach New York.
Wer es hier schafft,
schafft es überall.
Dachte sich auch Ronja Furrer.
Vor neun Jahren zog sie her.
Heute ist sie Topmodel.
Hi, how's it going?
- Good, how are you?
Thank you. Bye.
New York ist sicher
eine der wichtigsten Städte,
wie auch Paris und London
oder Mailand.
Für mich läuft es
jetzt seit acht Jahren mega gut.
Man muss sich überlegen, in welcher
Stadt es sinnvoll ist, zu leben.
Für mich ist es New York.
Ich fühle mich jetzt hier auch mehr
zu Hause als in jeder anderen Stadt.
Ronja kommt aus Lüterkofen
und hing am Rockzipfel der Mutter.
Ihr Grossvater schickte heimlich
ein Foto an eine Modelagentur
und legte damit den Grundstein
einer unerhörten Karriere.
Diese brachte die Schweizerin an
sämtliche Hotspots der Fashionwelt.
Ronja ist unser Topmodel.
Heute steht ein Shooting an. Ganz
unspektakulär nimmt Ronja die U-Bahn.
Es geht viel schneller
als mit dem Auto.
Ich liebe es, Leute zu beobachten.
Das geht am besten in der Subway.
* Dumpfe, dynamische Elektroklänge *
Ronja modelt seit 13 Jahren.
Ein Fototermin und ein neues Team
bringen sie
längst nicht mehr aus der Ruhe.
Was am wichtigsten ist und ich
sicher mache, ist pünktlich zu sein.
Das ist ja auch
etwas sehr Schweizerisches.
Ich bin nie zu spät,
sondern eher zu früh.
Das ist sicher etwas,
das Professionalität ausmacht.
Und dann lasse ich es
einfach mal auf mich zukommen.
Seit ihrem 14. Lebensjahr
behauptet sie sich
in der kurzlebigen Fashionwelt.
Ich mache dich frisch.
- Perfect.
When you're ready look up!
Heute keine Smokey Eyes,
keine roten Lippen.
Allüren hat Ronja keine.
Haltung schon.
Manchmal wird es auch ihr zu viel.
Mal mehr, mal weniger.
Manchmal hat man halt mehr Lust
und manchmal hat man gar keine Lust,
Hände im Gesicht zu haben.
Es kommt auch ... Während der Shows
ist es halt immer mega stressig.
Und da hast du manchmal
mehr als zwei Hände im Gesicht.
Es ist etwas sehr Persönliches,
wenn dir jemand so nahe kommt.
Es kommt auf den Moment an -
heute geht es gut.
* Entspannte Elektroklänge *
Sich selbst bleiben in einer Welt,
die einen ständig anders haben will,
das scheint das Geheimnis
des Schweizer Models zu sein.
Da bin ich in meinem Element.
Das Team ist mega gut.
Bis es mal ins Rollen kommt,
dann ist super.
Die Realität des Modelns
ist sicher weniger glamourös,
wie sich das viele wohl vorstellen.
Also ...
Es ist nicht der rote Teppich,
die Limousine oder der Privatjet.
Es ist ... das Gegenteil.
Aber ihre Kundenliste ist glamourös:
Chanel, Ralph Lauren
oder Tommy Hilfiger.
Du fliegst am gleichen Abend
nach Schweden,
arbeitest fünf Tage in Schweden.
Ah, wegen Hugo Boss.
Dann hast du hier noch
auf Los Angeles die Option.
Okay.
Und die Option in Paris.
- Ah, ja.
Ja, ja.
Also wird's ein anstrengender Monat.
Es ist ja schon Mitte Monat.
Bis Mai am Durcharbeiten.
Meist
kommen die Aufträge kurzfristig rein
und werfen private Pläne
über den Haufen.
Das Anstrengende ist sicher,
dass man oft alleine ist.
Man hat mit Einsamkeit zu kämpfen.
Du bist fast nie zu Hause.
Du weisst nicht, was morgen ist.
Du musst sehr flexibel sein,
da die Jobs sehr spontan reinkommen.
Du musst ...
Du kannst nichts planen.
Ich hatte schon oft Ferien
oder Familientreffen geplant,
die ich dann absagen musste,
weil ich einen Job hatte.
Ronja Furrer und Roger Federer -
neben ihren Initialen
verbinden sie Tugenden,
die als typisch schweizerisch gelten.
Bye guys, see you tomorrow.
Thank you so much!
Harte Arbeit,
Bodenständigkeit und Respekt.
* Dynamische, dumpfe Trommelklänge *
Keine 2. Std.
von Mexiko-City entfernt
lebt der Schweizer Karl Kieliger.
Ich bin froh, in Mexiko zu sein
und hier arbeiten zu dürfen.
Ich brauche das Radfahren
als Ausgleich zur Arbeit.
Da ich v.a. Kopfarbeit mache,
bin ich froh, wenn ich abends oder
frühmorgens Fahrrad fahren kann -
oder am Wochenende.
Sport treiben,
draussen sein, Bewegung haben,
das sind auch Kindheitserinnerungen.
Wir waren sehr aktiv
und unternahmen viel.
Das ist schön. Ich bin froh, das
in Puebla weiterführen zu können.
Schon als Bub träumte Karl Kieliger
von der grossen weiten Welt
und einem Schweizer Sackmesser.
Später zog es den Manager
nach Lateinamerika.
In Mexiko steht er als Länderchef
für das Swiss Army Knive,
das längst zur Ikone geworden ist.
Vor 15 Jahren
wurde Südamerika sein Zuhause.
Der gebürtige Urner
lebt seit seiner Scheidung alleine.
Der Schweiz bleibt er treu:
(Jingle) ... SRF 3.
- SRF 3.
Wenn ich einen Tag lang nicht DRS 3
höre, fehlt mir irgendwie etwas.
Ich finde das so gut:
Mit dem Internet kann man
von überall Schweizer Radio hören.
So bin ich mit der Schweiz verbunden
und weiss immer, was läuft.
Wenn mich Freunde besuchen,
machen sie Witze und fragen:
"Wie lautet
die Staumeldung zum Gotthard?"
Man bekommt sehr viel mit und
ich weiss, was in der Schweiz läuft.
Die vielen Jahre im Ausland
haben seinen Blick auf die Heimat
verändert:
Wenn man im Ausland lebt, wird man
fast zu einem besseren Schweizer:
Man hört,
was in der Schweiz läuft,
welche Probleme aktuell sind,
von denen ich denke: Das sind keine.
Wenn ich sehe, wie es hier abläuft
in der Politik, der Regierung ...
Dann sieht man vieles nicht mehr
so eng, was in der Schweiz läuft.
So sehe ich das.
(Radio) ... von den letzten Tagen:
Deo lohnt sich.
Jürg Zogg von "SRF Meteo" ...
Lateinamerika
habe ich ganz sicher im Herzen.
Gerade
die Herzlichkeit der Menschen.
Ich liebe dieses Land, ich liebe
die Menschen. Ich bin gerne hier.
Hola, buenas tardes.
- Hola.
Die Erwartungen an Karl Kieliger
sind hoch.
Mit seinem Team soll er dieses Jahr
für ein Wachstum von 10 % sorgen.
Das sind die Erwartungen
des Mutterhauses in Ibach.
Victorinox
ist heute in vierter Generation.
Das verpflichtet,
die Familieninteressen wahrzunehmen.
Wir haben 295 Angestellte.
Ich bin auch für sie verantwortlich,
dass sie ihren Lohn bekommen,
ein Einkommen haben,
dass wir die Firma vorwärtsbringen
und sie profitabel ist.
Dass Kieliger für seine Firma
der Richtige am richtigen Ort ist,
zeigt er mit einer neuen Kollektion.
Ich bin neugierig, zu sehen,
wo wir jetzt stehen.
Wir arbeiten mit indigenen
Kunsthandwerkern zusammen.
Das sind die ersten Muster.
Okay, muy bien. Si.
Das ist
ein typisch mexikanisches Design,
mit verschiedenfarbigen Perlen.
Die Perlen bilden ein Muster.
Das ist ein sehr bekanntes Kunst-
handwerk hier in Mexiko: Huichol.
Sehr schön, gefällt mir gut.
Ich werde dieses Muster in der
Schweiz mit Victorinox anschauen
und diskutieren.
Erfolgreich werden ist das eine,
erfolgreich bleiben das andere.
Zu Hause in Manhattan arbeitet Ronja
an ihrem digitalen Auftritt,
der immer wichtiger wird:
Das ist meine Homepage.
Und hier ist mein Portfolio.
Das war damals
für die "Vogue Paris".
Man sagt,
dass die französische "Vogue"
eines der wichtigsten Magazine
im Fashion-Business ist.
Diese Bilder
bereiten mir wirklich grosse Freude,
da es viel harte Arbeit war,
die sich dann so ausbezahlte.
Sie hat es geschafft, aber
die ersten Gehversuche waren hart.
14-jährig in Paris:
Ich weiss es noch genau.
Ich kam mit dem Zug an,
konnte kein Wort Französisch,
hatte nur ein paar Euro
in der Tasche. Ich hatte kein Handy.
Man hatte mir gesagt, dass jemand
am Bahnhof auf mich warten würde.
Es war aber niemand dort.
Nach 10-15 Min. kam dann jemand
mit einem Schild mit meinem Namen.
Er hat mich direkt
zu einem Testshooting gefahren.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung,
was ein Testshooting ist,
was da passiert,
was ich machen muss.
Das war dieser Moment:
mein erstes Testshooting in Paris.
Es war mega schwierig: Du wirst
einfach ins kalte Wasser geworfen.
* Nachdenkliche
elektronische Klänge *
Irgendjemand hat das hochgeladen.
Ich weiss nicht, wer.
* Remix-Version von "A Little Less
Conversation" von Elvis Presley *
Ich sehe nicht wirklich aus,
als hätte ich Lust.
Aber ich hatte Spass.
Ronja hat sich
mit Anstand nach oben gekämpft.
Schlagzeilen von Partyexzessen oder
Drogen machte die Schweizerin nie.
Die Bodenhaftung
habe sie nie verloren.
Also eine typische Schweizerin.
Ich glaube, die Schweiz
ist einfach mein Blut und mein Herz.
Ich habe sicher viel mitgenommen
aus der Schweiz:
die Pünktlichkeit,
das Anständige,
dass man eher zurückhaltend ist,
statt einfach rauszugehen und ...
... rumzuschreien.
* Langsame, verspielte Klänge *
Aber auch sie hatte Krisen:
Ein Bandscheibenvorfall brachte
die 27-Jährige an ihre Grenzen.
Seitdem achtet sie noch mehr auf ihre
Gesundheit. Und auf mentale Stärke.
Deshalb hat sie mit Boxen angefangen.
Das helfe.
Ich boxe sehr gern,
da ich so meine Frustrationen
und Aggressionen abbauen kann.
Immer wenn ich komme
und nicht so gut gelaunt bin,
gehe ich erfrischt
und offen für Neues wieder hinaus.
Es gibt mir
ein gewisses Selbstvertrauen.
Ich weiss, dass ich mich wehren
kann. Und es macht mir mega Spass.
Bin ich immer noch so steif?
- Ach, du bist gut.
Sag's mir ruhig.
- Du bist okay.
Mein Problem ist,
dass ich mich oft versteife,
v.a. oben und im Nacken.
Ich bin so ...
Das kommt wohl von meinen Job,
man nennt das Modelnacken.
You know, like ...
- Like you're out like this?
Darum sagt er immer: "Relax!"
Aber das Business ist hart:
Vor Fashionshows
muss Ronja fast so intensiv trainie-
ren wie eine Spitzensportlerin.
Hast du das gesehen?
- Yeah, it's good!
Es ist wie ein Job.
Wenn ich mich
auf die Fashion Week vorbereite,
gehört auch die Ernährung dazu.
Mit ganz ...
Ich muss ein Programm durchziehen
und diszipliniert sein.
Ronja, eine moderne Version
der Räubertochter, so scheint es,
mutig und selbstbestimmt.
Aber da sind auch andere Momente.
Dann vermisst sie die Familie
und ihren Liebsten, den Musiker
Andres Andrekson, bekannt als Stress.
Wir haben uns kennengelernt,
als ich bereits in New York war.
Es war von Anfang an
eine Fernbeziehung.
Und das funktioniert ... sehr gut.
Klar haben wir unsere Momente,
in denen es frustrierend ist,
weil wir nicht immer in Person da
sein können, wie wir gerne möchten.
Aber ich glaube, wir sind beide
zufrieden damit, wie es ist.
Wir sind beide
sehr zielstrebige Menschen.
Er ist sehr ehrgeizig in seinem Job,
ich in meinem auch.
Wir unterstützen einander und finden
immer einen Weg, uns zu sehen.
Das stimmt so für uns.
* Gläserne Klänge *
2 Std. fährt Karl Kieliger mit
seiner Mitarbeiterin nach Pachuca.
Dort lebt einer
der berühmtesten Köche des Landes,
der sich für sie Zeit nimmt.
Hola, buenas tardes.
- Hola.
Hola, Aquiles, como estas?
- Como estas?
Aquiles Chavez ist der Star
unter den mexikanischen Chefs.
Hier ist die Produktion.
- Ah, wie schön, guten Tag!
Hier machen wir alles, Brot, Saucen.
Das ist unsere Testküche.
Unten ist die Restaurantküche.
Und hier haben wir eine Zunge.
* Dynamische Xylophon-Klänge *
Aquiles und sein Team entwickeln die
traditionelle Küche Mexikos weiter.
Immer schon habe er gerne
mit den Messern aus Ibach gearbeitet,
sagt Chavez.
Der Koch ist Influencer für
Victorinox. Seine Videos gehen viral.
Die Qualität der Videos
ist sehr gut.
Sie sind vielleicht
nicht gerade künstlerisch,
aber sie sind einzigartig.
Doch,
man kann es künstlerisch nennen.
Chefs wie du, Gourmets, Köche,
die die Küche weiterbringen,
haben stark an Bedeutung gewonnen.
Ja, wir werden langsam zu Rockstars.
Rockstars der Küche.
Der 42-jährige Spitzenkoch hat sich
auch in der Schweiz weitergebildet:
Das war fast militärisch in der
Schweiz, v.a. die Pünktlichkeit,
keine Minute zu spät. Alles muss
ganz pünktlich sein. Schweizer Zeit.
Das ist sehr schweizerisch.
Ja, ich glaube, eure Fröhlichkeit,
das Spektakel und wir Schweizer,
das ist eine sehr gute Kombination.
Mexikanischer Enthusiasmus
und Schweizer Geschäftssinn,
das klingt
nach einer Win-win-Situation.
Gracias, chao, chao.
Bye, bye.
* Verspielte, gläserne Klänge *
Jeden zweiten Donnerstagabend
hat der 46-jährige Schweizer
ein Rendez-vous.
Guten Abend, können Sie ein Auge
auf das weisse Auto haben? Danke.
Gracias.
Hallo, Hans, salü.
- Willkommen!
Danke für die Einladung.
- Gut.
Salü, Jean-Paul, grüezi.
- Freut mich, bist du da.
Die Deutschschweizer Community
von Puebla
trifft sich
zum traditionellen Jassabend.
Hallo, Willy.
- Salü, hoi.
Cuba Libre.
Cuba Libre? Mit Bacardi Blanco oder
mit Matusalem? - Blanco, blanco.
Machst du mir bitte auch noch einen?
Machen wir einfachen Rose?
In Mexiko ist manch ein Schweizer
reich geworden - auch erfolgreich.
Die meisten hier sind Geschäftsleute.
Sie haben mich sehr gut aufgenommen,
als ich vor zwei Jahren hierherkam.
Es ist fantastisch,
die Kameradschaft zu pflegen,
die Schweizer Tradition ... Zusammen
zu jassen, das macht extrem Spass.
Auch beim Essen
pflegt man Traditionen:
Das ist die Spezialität heute Abend
zur Vorspeise.
Meine Freunde wollen immer,
wenn ich dran bin,
dass ich eine Sulzplatte mache.
Das ist ein Rezept meiner Mutter
aus Schaffhausen.
Das schmeckt allen sehr gut.
Es ist typisch schweizerisch.
Das findet man hier nicht. Wie zu
Hause. Wir fühlen uns hier zu Hause.
Wie zu Hause. Und doch gibt es
auch deutliche Unterschiede:
Alles in Ordnung?
Die Lampe und die Pfeife.
Das ist
auch eine aus dem Rotary Club.
Was heisst "vecino" auf Deutsch?
Nachbarn, die Wache halten.
"Vecino Vigilante" heisst das.
* Tröte erklingt. *
Wenn etwas ist,
kann er Alarm schlagen,
und wir wissen, wenn etwas los ist.
Einmal, als Hans gerade die Löhne
ausbezahlte, wurde er überfallen:
Sie kamen mit Pistolen rein, nahmen
den Arbeitern den Geldbeutel ab,
Uhren, Ringe,
natürlich das ganze Geld.
Wir müssen einfach immer aufpassen.
Man darf z.B.
die Tore nicht mehr offen lassen
oder man muss jemanden
Wache halten lassen.
Damit müssen wir hier halt leben.
Die Schweizer, die sich die Heimat
nach Mexiko geholt haben,
gelten als reich,
zuverlässig und pünktlich.
Das fördert das Geschäft, aber:
Wenn man sieht, wie es hier läuft
mit den Behörden, in der Politik,
und das mit der Schweiz vergleicht -
es gibt in der Schweiz
kaum Bürokratie, alles läuft.
Wenn man einen Ausweis haben muss,
kommt man schnell dazu.
Hier ist es z.T. schwierig.
Ein Unterschied ist auch,
dass man sich hier gar nicht sicher
fühlt, wenn die Polizei kommt.
Mir wurden mal Portemonnaie
und Schlüssel geklaut,
nachdem ich einen Unfall
gehabt hatte.
Die Polizisten sind einfach
die legal bewaffneten Kriminellen.
Und dennoch
ist Mexiko ihr Zuhause geworden.
Kaum einer denkt an eine Rückkehr
in die Schweiz.
(Alle) Prost!
* Verspielte, gläserne Klänge *
Federer!
I love ya!
- Thank you!
Roger Federer und seine Fans, das ist
eine regelrechte Liebesgeschichte.
Wo immer er hinkommt,
löst er einen Rummel aus,
dem der Schweizer mit Bescheidenheit
und Freundlichkeit begegnet.
* Rufe *
Anstehen, den Zaun stehenlassen!
Für diese Nahbarkeit
verehren ihn die Fans -
oft mit bedingungsloser Ergebenheit,
wie die Australierin Helen:
Ich folge ihm
in Australien überall hin,
ich stehe um 1, 2 oder 3 Uhr nachts
auf, wo immer er in Europa spielt,
ich verpasse keinen Match.
In Wimbledon
habe ich ihn dreimal gesehen.
Ich war fünfmal in der Schweiz,
übernachtete in einer Jugendherberge
mit Blick auf sein Haus.
Er ist wunderschön,
bescheiden, grossartig.
Es ist sehr anstrengend,
ihm nachzureisen.
Wenn er verliert, spreche ich
drei Tage lang mit niemandem.
In meinem Nachruf
habe ich geschrieben:
"Helens grösste Liebe war Federer,
dann die Familie."
Ich liebe Roger Federer,
ich weine, ich bin verrückt,
aber so ist das eben.
Und obwohl die Fans
es nicht gerne hören:
Der 38-Jährige hat Pläne
für ein Leben nach dem Tenniszirkus.
Ich fühle mich
zwar überall auf der Welt wohl,
aber es ist auch wichtig,
dass ich dort oft
Familie und Freunde dabei habe.
Aber am liebsten
bin ich in der Schweiz.
Darum haben Mirka
und ich entschieden,
dass wir am liebsten immer
in die Schweiz zurückkommen wollen,
auch dort wohnen wollen. Unsere
Kinder sollen dort aufwachsen.
Frei zu leben, trotz Prominenz, ein
Privileg, das die Schweiz ermöglicht.
Ich glaube,
das sind Werte der Schweiz.
Der Respekt und ...
Wir können uns glücklich schätzen,
dass unser Land so schön ist,
sicher, dass alles funktioniert.
Du kannst zu Fuss
in den Kindergarten gehen.
Das ist nicht in jedem Land möglich.
Du kannst mit dem Fahrrad
zur Schule, wie ich früher.
Das geht nicht überall.
Das ist wirklich Luxus,
dass wir diese Freiheiten
in unserem Land haben.
Auch den Respekt,
den wir einander entgegenbringen,
die Privatsphäre,
dass wir
einander nicht stören wollen,
dass man erst freundlich fragt:
"Darf ich?"
Das ist bei uns sehr willkommen.
Und wir können uns
glücklich schätzen, dass es so ist.
In die Welt hinausgehen,
um zu suchen, was einem fehlt,
und dann nach Hause zurückkehren,
um es zu finden.
Vielleicht ist auch das
ein Schweizer Charakterzug.
Perfekt, danke.
Was ist der typische Schweizer?
Das kann ich
nur sehr schwer erklären.
Einer,
dem es in der Schweiz gefällt,
der findet, die Schweiz
sei das schönste Land der Welt,
ist für mich
ein richtiger Schweizer.
* Schweizerpsalm *
Im Tennis wird sehr selten
die Nationalhymne gespielt.
Das passiert nicht häufig.
Aber ich höre sie
natürlich immer gerne.
Es gibt einem
noch mehr das Gefühl von Zuhause.
Hier sieht man
sehr viele Schweizer Fahnen.
Die Schweizer zeigen sich
und schreien viel mehr hier.
Ich bin unheimlich stolz, aber
das wissen die Schweizer sowieso.
(Kommentator) Es sind 20!
Und wir zählen gerne weiter.
Roger Federer
liess sich nicht aufhalten
und hielt an seiner Vision fest:
Es ist wichtig, dass man
den Sportlern hilft, zu träumen.
Ich glaube, im Sport ist es
ganz wichtig, den Glauben zu haben,
es schaffen zu können.
Und nicht nur der Beste im Raum
Basel zu werden oder in der Schweiz,
sondern sogar der Beste der Welt
werden zu dürfen.
(Kommentator)
Für die Geschichtsbücher.
Es ist geschafft!
Das ist Sportgeschichte,
meine Damen und Herren!
* Emotionale Klavierklänge *
Auf der Linie!
Das, meine Damen und Herren,
ist der nackte Wahnsinn.
Karl Kieliger
ist im Kanton Uri aufgewachsen.
Regelmässig zieht es ihn
in die Heimat zurück.
Es ist faszinierend, durch
die schöne grüne Schweiz zu fahren,
die Berge zu sehen. Es ist Heimat.
Viele Erinnerungen an die Kindheit,
an schöne Momente mit Freunden
und Familie. Das macht immer Spass.
Hier in Ibach
hat er früher gearbeitet.
Das Familienunternehmen Victorinox
wird für seine Innovationskraft
und sein nachhaltiges Management
regelmässig ausgezeichnet.
Carl Elsener,
der CEO und Urenkel des Gründers,
nimmt sich Zeit
für seinen Mann in Mexiko.
Die Idee ist, dass wir
eine Serie mit vier Messern machen
in typisch mexikanischen Designs.
Da wir sehr viele Fans haben
in Mexiko, die die Messer lieben,
werden sich die Mexikaner freuen,
wenn sie ihre Muster, ihre Kultur
auf einem Schweizer Taschenmesser
sehen.
Die Sackmesser aus Ibach
sind weltweit bekannt -
und sogar darüber hinaus:
Chris Hadfield
ist ein kanadischer Astronaut,
der mehr als 4'000 Std.
im Weltraum verbracht hat.
Er war in einem Spaceshuttle
und musste an die
russische Raumstation Mir andocken.
Die Russen hatten ihm Werkzeug
gegeben, um die Luke zu öffnen.
Das hat er versucht,
aber nicht geschafft.
Zuerst wollte er zurück,
um neues Werkzeug zu holen.
Dann fiel ihm ein:
"I have a Swiss Army Knife."
Im Buch schreibt er:
"So we did the true space age thing:
We broke into Mir
using a Swiss Army Knife."
Und der nächste Satz ist: "Never
leave the planet without one."
Und doch hebt man hier nicht ab
und feilt weiter an den Produkten.
Morgen zusammen.
- Hallo.
Mit seiner früheren Arbeitskollegin
begutachtet Karl Kieliger
die verbesserten Prototypen.
Jetzt sind wir gespannt, wie das ...
Jetzt sind die Perlen gross genug.
Was denkst du? - Ja.
Da sind wir ziemlich im Endstadium.
Das sieht gut aus.
Er ist immer noch gleich, sieht
immer noch gleich aus. - Danke.
Er ist immer noch der Gleiche.
- Da geben wir uns Mühe.
Es ist immer schön, ihn zu sehen.
Ich freue mich,
wenn er in die Schweiz kommt.
Von daher ist es schön.
Ich fühle mich
sofort wieder zu Hause.
Bei uns hat die Zusammenarbeit
von Anfang an gut funktioniert.
Wenn ich hierher komme,
sind das alte Erinnerungen.
Ich bin sofort wieder
in der Schweiz.
Es ist immer schön,
hierher zu kommen.
Heimatverbundenheit
gepaart mit Weltoffenheit
haben Karl geholfen,
seinen Bubentraum zu verwirklichen.
* Vogelzwitschern *
* Beschauliche Klänge *
Weit weg von New York,
in Lüterkofen im Kanton Solothurn.
Hier ist Ronja Furrers Wohlfühlort.
Aufgehoben in der Patchworkfamilie
ihrer Eltern.
Ich war ein richtiger Mamihöck.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich mal
selbstständig reisen würde.
Ich war immer diejenige,
die zu Hause bleiben wollte.
Früher, z.B. im Skilager,
war es extrem schwierig für mich,
zu gehen und Tschüss zu sagen.
Drum hätte ich nie gedacht, dass ich
diejenige der Familie sein würde,
die am meisten reist und in New York
lebt - so weit weg von der Familie.
Papa!
Ah, ich habe gar nicht ...
Ich dachte, du hättest mega Krach.
Wie viele sind wir?
- Ungefähr zehn.
Ich würde schon noch ein paar mehr.
Die Eltern brachten Ronja
stets viel Vertrauen entgegen.
Aber als die 14-Jährige
mutterseelenallein nach Paris reiste,
war auch dem Vater mulmig zumute.
Es war schon schwierig für mich,
jetzt ...
... sie aus diesem behüteten Kreis
rauszugeben, irgendwohin zu geben.
Das war nicht einfach,
definitiv nicht.
Die Mutter dagegen glaubte daran,
dass alles gut kommt, so oder so.
Sie wusste, dass sie jederzeit
abbrechen und heimkommen kann,
so sein kann, wie sie ist.
Das war mir am wichtigsten,
dass sie ihren Weg geht.
Und der ist von selbst entstanden.
Ich finde es schön,
wenn es im Leben einfach läuft,
und man es nimmt, wie es kommt.
Das ist halt ...
Das ist immer nur,
wenn du kommst, Ronja.
Immer, wenn du kommst,
gibt es Nutella.
Familienmensch Ronja fühlt sich
hier geborgen und aufgehoben.
Vielleicht haben sie diese
starken Wurzeln nie stolpern lassen.
In solchen Momenten ist das andere
Zuhause, New York, ganz weit weg.
Es ist eigentlich das Gegenteil,
weil es hier sehr persönlich ist
und weil es sie auch wirklich
interessiert, wie es mir geht -
hoffe ich zumindest.
Auch das Dorf,
das ist das Gegenteil von New York,
auch vom Leben in New York.
Ich brauche das auch sehr, hier
in Lüterkofen oder in der Schweiz.
Es gibt mir
extrem viel Kraft und ... Energie.
Es war sensationell.
- Es war mega.
Oder?
- Gut, weisst du das.
Du hast das gesagt.
- Nein, es war mega ...
Ich musste
zuerst noch Andres anrufen.
Ich wusste nicht,
ob ich das Hotel umbuchen kann.
Ihr wolltet jetzt nach Chile?
Nein, wir gehen auf die Malediven.
Ah?
- Ach so.
Ah, habe ich das nicht gesagt?
- Nein!
Ich muss jedenfalls morgen
für einen Tag nach New York.
Sie meinten, ich könne von den
Malediven nach New York und zurück.
Aber das sind 21 Std. Reise.
Du hast doch manchmal
dieses Melatonin genommen, oder?
Die Natur gibt ihr ebenfalls Halt.
Hoi, Coolman.
Hoi, du.
Bist du bereit?
Er heisst Coolman, was ich
einen mega coolen Namen finde.
Normalerweise
sind Hengste ziemlich ...
Ja ...
Sie wollen einfach etwas.
Und er ist sehr cool.
Der Name passt.
Er hat grosse Lust
auf einen Ausritt.
Er gähnt immer,
aber wenn man ihn rausnimmt,
freut er sich schon, dass wir gehen.
Beim Ausritt mit der Schwester
schmiedet Ronja
auch schon mal Zukunftspläne.
Es ist sicher ein Traum von mir,
eine Familie zu haben,
vielleicht auch mal eine Ausbildung
im sozialen Bereich zu machen.
Ich habe einige Ideen,
aber momentan konzentriere ich mich
noch voll auf das Modeln.
Wir sind sehr verwöhnt
in der Schweiz.
Wir haben alles, es ist sicher.
In der Schweiz aufzuwachsen
ist für Kinder etwas vom Schönsten.
Deshalb glaube ich, dass es mich
wieder in die Schweiz ziehen wird.
Mehr Erfolgsgeschichten
in einer Woche:
Philomena Schwab ist die Überflie-
gerin in der Schweizer Gamerszene.
Dem Silicon Valley
gibt sie einen Korb,
denn sie träumt
von einem Silicon Valley in Zürich.
Carlos Marbach
ist Profikäser aus Leidenschaft.
Mit schweizerischer excellence coacht
er Unternehmer in der Mongolei.
Der ehemalige Profibiker
Claudio Caluori
baut heute Pumptracks
in der ganzen Welt.
Good job, ey!
Und macht Kindern Hoffnung
auf eine bessere Zukunft.